un marché de noël virtuel pour pallier
l'absence d'exposants cette année des
créatrices de saint quentin en yvelines
se sont réunis par le biais d'un groupe
facebook pour vendre leurs produits
une idée à l'initiative de cette
créatrice dans la mesure où tous les
marchés s'annuler les uns après les
autres il a fallu trouver un moyen de se
faire connaître de profiter un petit peu
de cette opportunité pour vendre nos
créations sur un autre biais comme les
réseaux sociaux ali la création du
groupe facebook date du 7 novembre
dernier
chacune y va de sa publication pour
présenter ses créations et un stock que
je prends en photo
donc ça fait une base pour que les
clients ne se rend compte de ce dont il
s'agit et puis après deux options soit
en fait les clientes ont vu ce qu'ils
avaient en stock
la trousse par exemple et du coup a
décidé d'acheter celle là donc du coup
elle
on voit un petit message soit 1,10 à
j'aime bien est ce que vous l'avez dans
une autre couleur à moi de coudre en
fait pour rester dans les délais de noël
voilà qui se rapproche au total huit
créatrice font partie du marché de noël
virtuel au catalogue créations textiles
peintures ou encore zéro déchet une
initiative locale dans le domaine de la
création artisanale
nous notre cible souhaitée c'est
vraiment la clientèle de proximité de
faire fonctionner le bouche à oreille et
puis de proposer des produits qui sont
plus locale que ça c'est pas possible
quoi enfin je veux dire on dit tout de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines montigny
guyancourt voisins donc c'est vraiment
du fait-main cdu local c'est l'artisanat
le marché de noël virtuels à des
créatrices de saint quentin en yvelines
a déjà attiré plus de 700 personnes